BUT NOW IT IS TIME TO PLAY SQUAD
GOALS, SCHMOD GOALS.
THERE'S A RARE NEW TWITTER TREND
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
TRYING TO GET FINGERED BY A
MEMBER OF ONE DIRECTION.
IT'S CALLED SQUAD GOALS, AND YOU
CAN DO THAT?
OH, MAN!
>> WHY ARE WE SITTING HERE ON A
GAME SHOW.
>> Chris: I'VE BEEN WRITING
SNAIL-MAIL LETTERS.
IT IS CALLED SQUAD GOALS AND
PEOPLE ARE USING IT TO POST DOPE
PICS OF SWEET CREWS THEY'D LIKE
TO ROLL WITH.
I AM GOING TO SHOW YOU A
PHOTO WE FOUND BY SEARCHING
SQUAD GOALS AND FOR 250 POINTS I
WANT YOU TO TELL ME THE NAME OF
THIS SQUAD.
FIRST ONE, THESE FOXY LADIES.
HEATHER
>> TOO FAT, TOO FURIOUS
(BLEEP).
I'M SORRY.
>> Chris: I MEAN, IT IS KIND
OF... RIGHT THERE.
DAN.
>> THE "WE RUN EVERYTHING
WEST OF JOANNE FABRICS" POSSE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JEFF.
>> LIVE FAST DIABETES.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, THESE
FOREST FRIENDS.
THESE FOREST FRIENDS.
WHAT IS THIS CREW CALLED?
>> DAN HARMON.
>> THE AMBER ALERTS.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, THESE
FELLAHS, THESE FELLAHS.
JEFF DAVIS.
>> THE GLUTEN FREE MASONS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT COULD BE
ANYTHING ELSE, QUITE FRNAKLY.
BUT LET'S FIND OUT.
HEATHER.
>> THE CATCHERS OF THE RYE.
>> OH!
>> Chris: VERY ACADEMIC.
>> LITERALLY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> THEY LITERALLY CAUGHT RYE.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE.
THIS THING, THAT THING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND, WHAT ARE YOU
UPSET ABOUT?
SHUT UP, KIDS. THIS IS WHAT LIFE
IS LIKE.
YOU GOTTA LEARN SOONER OR LATER.
>> Chris: HEATHER.
>> THIS IS JUST A TYPICAL GERMAN
PLAYGROUND.
>> Chris: POINTS.
DAN.
>> A SCIENTOLOGIST WEDDING RING.
HERE, I'LL DO A DIFFERENT ONE IN
CASE THEY WRITE IN.
A METAPHOR FOR CAPITALISM.
>> Chris: DAN, DAN, DAN.
WE ARE USING THE SCIENTOLOGY
ONE.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
>> Chris: LAST ONE, THESE
SNAZZY SUBURBANITES.
WHAT IS THIS CREW?
DAN, GO.
>> THE FAMILY WHOSE ANSWERS TO
MARY (BLEEP) KILL IS ALWAYS EACH
OTHER.
>> Chris: WHAT AN INVOLVED NAME.
I MEAN, POINTS.
JEFF.
>> THE BUKHAKIS.
>> Chris: yYES, POINTS. OF
COURSE.